this week on brian ross investigates
anchors a muck
scandal in the u.s navy hookers payoffs
and top admirals all the work of one man
called fat leonard fat leonard has
pleaded guilty to corrupting the u.s
navy and creating a mafia-like
organization inside the navy
but now that leonard is speaking out
claiming a cover-up to protect even
higher level admirals and officials they
didn't want to clean house they just
wanted to like you know shuffle you know
like
shove this all under the carpet
let me take the take the blame and a
couple of other
bad apples and he trusted only one
reporter to tell his story and he's with
us tonight as you know it's
unprecedented for people who have plea
deals with the us government to talk
like this um very very very strange
the plus appears time for maximum impact
hundreds injured seventeen left as
amputees three dead
now the supreme court will decide if the
boston marathon bomber dzhokhar tsarnaev
should face the death penalty as a jury
decided
i really think it was the demeanor of
jahar himself in court he
you know hardly expressed remorse a
court overturned the jury sentence but
now government lawyers tell the court he
should be put to death president biden
is the first president to have said that
he opposes the death penalty
and it seems contradictory
for his justice department
to be pursuing its own appeal of the
death sentence was overturned
and this week's winners and losers in
the media is chosen by the editors of
mediaite see if you agree
from the law and crime trial network
this is bryan ross investigators
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague here at law and
crime rhonda schwartz and ronda we begin
with a huge corruption scandal that few
people have ever heard of it involves
the u.s navy top admirals and a man by
the name of fat leonard who used hookers
cash and his charm to win millions of
dollars in navy contracts in ports
across the pacific rhonda
his full name is leonard glenn francis a
350-pound malaysian man whose scheme
thrived for nearly a decade until u.s
prosecutors finally caught him in a
sting he recently pleaded guilty
becoming a star witness against navy
brass and now he's speaking out in a new
podcast series by the only journalist he
trusted to tell his story
and we're joined now by tom wright
former wall street journal reporter and
author who really broke the story of fat
leonard and tom thanks so much for being
here how did you get him to talk to you
after your stuff for investigative
reporting well it's an extraordinary
situation brian i mean fat leonard has
pleaded guilty to corrupting the u.s
navy and creating a mafia-like
organization inside the navy
partly what's going on here is he
believes there's been a cover-up in the
u.s navy and a lot of the information
that he gave to investigators about
admirals that dealt with him wasn't
acted upon in his view and that's one of
the reasons that he talked initially
i was the bad guy you know me i was mr
bad
look at what you did you know it was all
my fault
but as the case rolled forward you know
and the navy was like pushing back
because they didn't wanna
they didn't want to clean house they
just wanted to like you know shove their
you know like
shove this all under the carpet
let me take the take the blame and a
couple of other
bad apples you know three or four
the other is that he's he's got kidney
cancer late stage and so he's he's very
sick and i think that that also spurred
him to really spill the beans on this
extraordinary story
it's huge risk for me to you know do
what i'm doing but i'm so upset with it
well i'm portrayed as the bad guy when i
wasn't the bad guy i did everything that
they wanted me to do i've lived my life
i've been up just close to heaven and
down hell
i've seen it all
so
my legacy is important too we're all
going to die one day and i only fear god
i don't fear nobody else
and the story that's been out there is
that he corrupted a few navy officers
with prostitutes vacations you know
handbags for their wives that kind of
thing in return for
very very very large contracts to
protect the navy to provide food and
fuel and security to the ships but you
know as i investigated more and it isn't
just talking to leonard this podcast
it's you know multiple uh sources but
leonard was actually an integral part of
the navy for 25 years he he protected
the navy after september the 11th with a
with a product called the ring of steel
which were steel barges around the the
aircraft carriers the ring of steel is
the barriers the steel barriers
that protects the ships
from
a ship-borne attack like what happened
in the coal
he was a bag man for the navy he opened
up ports in in various places in asia
where you have to pay off people to be
able to get in and that's that's the
dirty secret of naval operations you
need someone like leonard
the entire command the chain of command
the command and control had to be in
your pocket
and that's what happened everybody was
in my pocket
i had them in my
palm i was just rolling them around
and then i could just move the carriers
like you know uh
paper ships in the in the water
nuclear powered aircraft carriers
strike groups
and i could like
put them in anywhere i wanted them to go
so he was extremely extremely useful to
the navy as well as as well as
corrupting
so this says a lot about the u.s navy
well yes when they wanted to take the
uss nimitz uh one at the time the
world's largest aircraft carrier into
india to send a signal to china that the
us was really you know the most powerful
navy in the indian ocean they relied on
leonard to come from singapore i know
miles and miles away to bring ships to
support that visit um and
so leonard was you know he was an
operator but
um he also
you know he there's a quote in the in
from him in the podcast where he says i
played professional and i played sexual
anything you want i did it
you know i played
professional
i play
sexual
whatever you need anything
one of the most amazing parts of this
story which is a huge national security
failure by the ux that again i don't
think has been fully understood is that
leonard actually recorded says he
recorded 4gs involving navy officers by
putting
secret cameras into the karaoke machines
that he would install in the suites of
hotels where he put on these events
yeah they just start stripping and you
know having sex right there
there was a mass orgy
that's how deep we were with the navy
that's how close we were we're touching
skins
i have a source who told me a very good
source he told me that the us has been
informed uh by china that channel
a back channel uh way of talking between
the countries that they actually have
some of this compromise and so that
that's a possible way that
some of this information
some of the the sexual compromise and
also some of the classified details he
had about ballistic missile defenses and
ship schedules you know may have fallen
into chinese hands
and how high up in the navy did this
corruption go
well it went very high but the the
trials that that are ongoing involve the
chief of staff of the seventh fleet you
know which is the very very top of the
the big fleet in the pacific which is
based in japan you know all the way down
to petty officers so it runs the whole
gamut leonard's point is that there were
also a lot of admirals that for whom he
he provided prostitutes and dinners and
those those admirals have not been
sentenced and they gave him what he
calls top cover so it meant that
over the years nothing nothing happened
he was able to push back all those
whistleblowers
and at this point who is the
highest-ranking u.s navy official who
has uh either been uh indicted or
convicted
so one navy admiral has gone to jail in
this um admiral gilbo robert gilbert
he's the first uh serving navy admiral
to go uh to jail in the in us history um
and he's out of jail already um he
he was actually convicted for false
statement i think or um
about two investigators about what what
went on with leonard he did his time
he's done his time in jail and he's out
um there's another admiral admiral bruce
loveless who is has pleaded not guilty
and is one of those seven who who's
pleaded not guilty and his trial is
upcoming so those are the most senior
people um caught up in this so far but
uh bottom line this is a huge scandal
that most people really have never heard
of that the navy has done a pretty good
job of keeping quiet yeah but people
just haven't heard of it um not here in
singapore where you know leonard francis
lived in a 130 million dollar mansion
with 20 luxury cars you know all thanks
to the u.s taxpayer
um
nobody knows about it and i think in the
us maybe it's a little bit better known
but again not not very and i think the
main reason for that is that no one's
been talking so now you know we hope
with fat leonard to really
uh shine a light on it and to sort of
spot more of a discussion about what
went wrong and how how this could be
stopped in the future
tom wright thank you so much for being
with us this evening
thank you
we asked the u.s navy for a comment a
spokesperson said given the ongoing
criminal investigation there would be no
comment well coming up next the young
man responsible for the boston marathon
bombing that killed and maimed so many
does he deserve the death penalty now in
the hands of the supreme court
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galvado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
we turn now to a question of life or
death a jury found that convicted boston
marathon bomber dzhokhar tsarnaev should
be sentenced to death but a higher court
overruled that decision now the case has
made it to the supreme court which heard
arguments about it earlier this month
to get a better understanding of what's
involved in this case we're joined now
by michelle mcphee a journalist who
covered the marathon bombing from the
moment the bombs went off all the way
through the trial and she's written a
book about it maximum hard and robert
dunham who's the executive director of
the death penalty information center mr
dunham to start with you uh the justices
seem to be favoring according to reports
uh reinstating the death penalty
yeah i i don't think that the uh
that the oral argument was a surprise
the conservative justices on the court
uh all seemed to line up with the
government's argument
that the first circuit had improperly
overturned tsarnaev's death sentence
and the liberal justices uh pretty much
sided with the with the first circuit uh
saying that the decision was uh was
appropriately granted
and michelle mcphee you covered the
trial uh the jury did vote the death
penalty but not all of the victims
favored the death penalty right
no i mean it was pretty split down the
middle you know
you're talking about hundreds of people
who were wounded 260 people 17 people
who were left amputees and another three
that were murdered that day along with
the slain police officer uh it was
pretty split down the middle
and i think martin richards family said
it very eloquently
this is just going to be
a rehashing of their wounds over and
over and over again because we all know
that this is a long and drawn out and an
expensive battle in fact it's so costly
that the court has sealed
the cost of both his trial and his
ongoing appeal from the public
and why do you think the jury finally
did go with the death penalty given the
arguments by some of the victims not to
do so
i really think it was the demeanor of
jahar himself in court he he you know
hardly expressed remorse he did
apologize but his antics throughout the
entire trial i think really
infuriated not just the victims and the
you know first responders who were
affected directly i think the jury was
watching him doodle and scowl at people
and you may recall brian because you
were alongside me covering this trial
that rebecca gregory
finally demanded look at me look at me i
want you to see the pain you caused me
the pain you caused my son
and he looked up and kind of smirked at
her
in fact you might recall there was a
high-ranking police official who was so
angry at the way that dzhokhar was
behaving that he whispered under his
breath maggot as he walked off the stand
so i think johar did not do himself any
favors
by his shenanigans during his trial
mr dunham the biden administration has
put a moratorium on death sentences in
federal cases why are they arguing here
that the death penalty should be
reinstated
well i think that justice barrett got it
wrong when she said that there was a
moratorium on death sentences
what the government has actually done
with the biden justice department has
actually done
is temporarily halt seeking death
warrants
the
the administration has not halted uh
seeking new death sentences it has not
halted uh
opposing capital appeals uh so um
that that having said that this still
creates a problem because president
biden is the first president to have
said that he opposes the death penalty
uh and it seems contradictory uh for his
justice department uh to be pursuing its
own appeal of a death sentence was
overturned michelle mcphee you've talked
with a number of the families as they
watch this quote back and forth now this
is exactly what they feared right it
would drag on forever and just kind of
for them recreate the horror of that
terrible day
and that's exactly right so for them
every time he
is featured on the news or these
arguments go back and forth again
they're reminded of what they lost and
and i think
the richard family said it so eloquently
that the best way for their family to
move on is to
to
allow him to just spend the rest of his
life in prison and even in prison he has
made somewhat of a mockery of the
victims by suing the government
by suing the bureau of prisons this is
yet another expensive um
issue that he has
tied the victims up in and it was over
wearing the white hat
identical to the one he wore when he
smirked and dropped that backpack behind
a row of children
so i think that
they do have a valid point i mean i
think if you take the death penalty
argument off the table this has just
become a boondoggle for him and i think
he's enjoying being the center of
attention again and the major argument
that the families have is you know let's
let's not give him that glare let's not
put him back in the spotlight let's let
him finish out his days as he does now
largely in solitary confinement watching
directv alone
and mr dunham finally the supreme court
ruling on this that'll be the final word
that'll exhaust the appeals
no in fact if the supreme court rules in
favor of the prosecutors the case will
actually go back to the u.s court of
appeals for the first circuit to resolve
a number of issues they didn't reach
because they didn't need to
once they overturned the death penalty
they didn't have to get the other issues
and that could be problematic in a
number of respects uh first there's a
possibility that the first circuit will
grant relief again
and there's a very sensitive issue
one of the issues that was not resolved
was whether the jurors were actually
biased
and there are claims in front of the
circuit
in which the jury foreman i'm sorry i'm
sorry the jury 4 woman
posted social media posts that referred
to mr tsarnaev as a piece of garbage so
that's a very strong indicator that
there may be bias and
it's it's possible that the case goes
back to the first circuit and gets
overturned again
and if the court rules
against
mr tsarnaev
and he loses the next stage of the
appeals there's also the habeas corpus
stage after that so we're looking at
probably at least another decade
before the case even finishes judicial
review
my goodness all right well robert dunham
and michelle mcphee thank you so much
for joining us tonight a very valuable
insights this case is far from over
thank you brian thank you brian
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media see if you agree
with the editors of mediaite about what
they say about msnbc's rachel meadow
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of media which like the
law and crime trial network is part of
the dan abrams media empire aidan good
to have you here tonight you've chosen
as your winner this week rachel mallow
of msnbc why
right so fox news gets a lot of
attention for its ratings these days and
it is true that the network is the most
watched on cable news by far but one
trend that has emerged in the past few
months is that rachel maddow who's long
been the most watched host on msnbc is
really the only person not on fox news
who draws big numbers now we're talking
since january when cnn and msnbc surged
ahead of fox news uh in the aftermath of
the 2020 election since then fox news
has pulled back ahead is comfortably
back on top and cnn msnbc are
experiencing lows but when you look at
just msnbc and cnn in prime time last
week msnbc doubled cnn's ratings on
thursday and friday and that was really
all thanks to rachel maddow who draws
much higher ratings than her fellow
msnbc primetime hosts chris hayes and
lawrence o'donnell so the bottom line is
that while cnn msnbc's ratings are way
down in the biden era there's one
non-fox personality that still draws a
large audience and it's rachel maddow
and as you know there were reports
earlier this year that she has a new
contract that allows her to skip the
daily show and just do a show once a
week what about that
that's right so she signed a new
contract uh the daily beast reported uh
that it was worth about 30 million
dollars which is obviously a huge amount
of money um the daily beast also
reported that she's going to be ending
her nightly show next year
and will pivot to more of a weekly
format we'll be doing more stuff outside
of just the nightly show
for msnbc uh but she's still on with
msnbc through the 2024 election so she's
sticking around with the network um but
she's not going to be doing the nightly
show anymore which is obviously a huge
knock for msnbc uh if they do go ahead
with that plan um but they're still
gonna be paying her an enormous amount
of money uh to remain at the network
and let's talk about your uh loser this
week john roberts of fox news why john
roberts usually a pretty straight ahead
uh hard news reporter
usually yeah i think all of twitter was
waiting around this morning for the
first fox news host to suggest that the
death of colin powell who died of covid
despite being vaccinated uh was proof or
evidence that the vaccines don't work um
i did not have my money on john roberts
to be that fox news host but he tweeted
on monday morning and i have to hear uh
yeah you've got it up uh the fact that
colin powell died from a breakthrough
covet infection raises new concerns
about how effective the vaccines are
long term uh as many people reminded
roberts after he tweeted that it does
not raise new questions about the
vaccines as we knew all along vaccines
are not 100 percent effective in
preventing death from covet and i should
also point out that colin powell is 90
it was 84 years old when he died he had
uh mia
mialoma which is a cancer that weakens
your immune system uh now to john
roberts credit he deleted the tweet and
posted a follow-up explaining that he
supports vaccines but i don't think the
episode says anything good about the
kind of information that people who
watch fox are getting about vaccines if
uh one of their own anchors believes uh
something like this
and very quickly even though they have
their own mandates at fox news they
continue to talk about the horrors of
mandates
that's true uh to work at fox news uh
you either have to get the covet vaccine
or submit to daily testing um that said
vaccine mandates are still a big outrage
topic on fox news um which is obviously
a little touch of hypocrisy that doesn't
really make sense to uh someone like me
indeed but they continue to talk about
it there ain't mclaughlin thank you so
much editor-in-chief of mediaite and
thank you all for joining us here this
evening we'll back in next week thanks
for a great team here at law and crime
for getting us on the air and off the
air every week
[Music]
you